kein Start nur wenn man von lutzerat kein Gott
kein Staat nur der Mann von Nutzern nur damit
sie auch was was wird es hier na sie wollten doch
über lützerath sprechen ja schon aber doch nicht
so wie haben die Klimakrise ja schon gehört ja und
und sie feiern irgendeinen verkleideten Typen der
unschuldige Polizisten in schlammschutz in Mönch
von lutzerat muss man Wagner seine erste gelungene
Aktion eines Linken gegen die staatsmahlzeit der
Novemberrevolution 19 ja was tragen sie denn zu
diesem Kampf bei ja was hier das das sind alles
Studien zu der Frage ob die Kohle unter dem Tag
auch gar nicht tatsächlich für die deutsche
Energiesicherheit von Nöten ist das heißt wir
müssen uns erstmal einen Überblick verschaffen
über die ganze vielen Dank das ist sehr schön
so welches Tier hat ein Arschloch auf
dem Rücken ja und auf unsere Aufgabe
ist es diese Studien zu lesen und
kritisch einzuordnen und dann dann
am Ende am Ende festen Stand das RWE und
die Fossil Lobby Desinformation betreiben
gut erledigt kommen wir zu den Antworten
auf drängendere Fragen das Polizeipferd
hahaha das muss so schön sein ja endlich
mal über die böse polizeiherzin zu dürfen
einfach nur das Geschäft der Fossil Lobby
haben sie zu viel Pfefferspray inhaliert
haben sie wie das Taufbecken wenn sich der Diskurs
nur noch um die Polizei dreht dann geht das zu
lassen das ist großes über die Klimakrise ja das
ist das spielt nur denjenigen die Hände die die
keinerlei Interesse daran haben ihre fossilen
Geschäfte zu beenden und sie unterstützen ihn
auch noch obwohl sie wissen dass er seine alten
Reflexe nicht mal unter Kontrolle hat ich habe
wenigstens noch linke Reflexe sie zocken ja nicht
mal mehr wenn die Lutz die Bürger von Polizisten
im Auftrag von große Unternehmen verprügelt werden
sie macht die Polizei ist nicht das Problem ja die
Polizei wird nur von der Politik missbraucht
die Polizei ist das Problem es ist Aufgabe der
Polizei die herrschende Ordnung zu bewahren die
ihre Klimakrise produziert hat ja oder außerdem
wenn ich gestern geblitzt worden so das ist das
Niveau was wir machen jetzt gegen die Polizei weil
er hat zu schnell gefahren ist super wenn das
das Niveau ist super halten sie mal wunderbar
dann machen wir das doch so herzlich willkommen
zur anstatt mal da und Herren die Polizei ist
rassistisch klar Kriminalität gibt's gar
nicht Gewalt geht nur von der Polizei aus
so erledigt so komplex wollte ich gar nicht
ja für mich war ein Bullen ja grundsätzlich
ich bin nicht bei der nächsten Polizeikontrolle
verhaftet werden kein Problem was soll das jetzt
Anonymisierung also entschuldigen sie
bitte ich bin ja nicht derjenige im
Fernsehen die Polizei als rassistisch bezeichnet
hat das war ironisch gemeint und unser
Publikum wird ja noch verstehen was sie
also gehen wir gleich in medias Rees Herr von
Wagner warum nennen sie meinen ganzen Namen
gut
achtung Achtung hier spricht die Polizei
die Versammlung wird wegen Verstoß gegen das
Vermummungsverbot aufgelöst wie lange stehen
sie denn da schon ja lang genug dass sie die
Dinger jetzt wegwerfen können wie lange denn genau
sie haben gesagt das Polizeipferd und sie haben
alle gelacht alle ich habe es gesehen das ist ja
genau richtig gekommen und ich werde auch bleiben
ja die Polizei die richtet sich jetzt überall
Wachen ein wo die Rechtsordnung der Republik in
Frage gestellt wird keine Sorge dass das würden
wir hier niemals machen Frau wachtmeisterin ja
Polizeihauptmeisterin wir machen hier nichts
weiter als eine harmlose Sendung über die
Klimakrise ach so Werbung für die klimakao
nee also so würde ich diese Menschen ja nicht
bezeichnen die durchaus ja Gründe haben für ihre
spezielles Verhalten ich wäre eine Sendung über
die Polizei machen endlich ausgewogen auch
diese Vorurteile die gegenüber der Polizei
herrschen mal beiseite zu räumen erotop
habe ich das richtig verstanden ich soll
sagen wie viel Polizisten braucht
es um eine Glühbirne einzudrehen
kein die verprügeln den Fremden lieber im Dunkeln
totaler Anfang der Sendung und schon die Rassismus
wir sagen nicht dass die Polizei in Deutschland
rassistisch ist wie bitte ja aber aber sie ist
natürlich historisch so gewachsen dass sie
im Dienste der Mehrheitsgesellschaft immer
das Fremde beobachten sollte und deswegen
notwendigerweise strukturell rassistisch ist
wie bitte ich meine sie sind ja nicht persönlich
Rassistin sie sie sind sie sind strukturell viel
Spaß bei der nächsten Polizei Kontrolle davon
Wagner Differenzierung my ass was ist aus dem
grünen und innen hohl also unsere Uniform
sind mittlerweile blau ne Schnittlauch okay
was ich sagen wollte wie wir machen jetzt
hier endlich mal eine ausgewogene Sendung
über die Polizei ja und über die Gewalt ja die
die Polizisten bei ihrem aufforderungsvollen
Job durchaus erfahren eventuell auch
ausüben wie wir machen aber auch was über
den Rassismus ja den ist so bei der Polizei
gar nicht gibt weil sie sind ja dein Freund
und helfe mir machen aber auch was über klaren
Kriminalität aber ohne die die Minderheiten in
Deutschland zu stigmatisieren klingt extrem
anspruchsvoll wie wollen Sie das machen
das das macht er das macht er vielleicht nicht
mit dem Text aber ja nektarius warum oder
was vergessen was denn na das Abo und die
Glocke was dann war das hier alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug